최근 호주 정부가 중국과 연결된 투자자들에게 한 광산기업의 지분을 팔라고 명령했습니다.
기업 이름은 노던미네랄스.
이 회사가 개발하려는 것은 금도 아니고 리튬도 아니고 철광석도 아닙니다.
디스프로슘과 터듐입니다.
호주 재무장관은 중국과 연결된 투자자들에게 노던미네랄스 지분을 처분하라고 명령했습니다.
이들은 회사 지분 약 17%를 보유하고 있었고
중국 외교부는 국가안보라는 이름으로 정상투자를 방해한다고 반발했습니다.
겉으로는 외국인 투자 규제처럼 보입니다.
중국 자본이 호주 광산기업에 들어가려 했고 호주 정부가 막은 사건처럼 보입니다.
그런데 이 사건을 조금 더 깊이 들여다보면 훨씬 큰 그림이 나옵니다.
호주가 막으려는 것은 단순한 중국 자본이 아닙니다.
중국이 디스프로슘이라는 작은 금속을 통해 앞으로의 전기차와 풍력발전,
방산과 로봇산업의 목줄까지 계속 쥐고 가려는 그 구조입니다.
히토리 전쟁의 진짜 전장은 광산일까요?
아니면
그 광산에서 나온 흙을 실제 산업자원으로 바꾸는 정제공장일까요?
그리고 호주는 지금 중국과 히토리 전쟁을 시작한 걸까요?
아니면 미국과 일본, 호주가 함께 중국이 장악한 중히토리 질서에서 빠져나오려는
첫 번째 실전 단계에 들어간 것일까요?
이 질문을 이해하려면 먼저 디스프로슘이라는 낯선 금속부터 봐야 합니다.
디스프로슘은 이름부터 조금 특이합니다.
1886년 프랑스에서 이 원소가 분리됐을 때 연구자들은 너무 힘든 과정을 겪었습니다.
그래서 그리스어로 도달하기 어려운 것이라는 뜻을 가진 말에서
디스프로슘이라는 이름이 붙었습니다.
그런데 140년이 가까이 지난 지금도 여전히 도달하기 어렵습니다.
땅속에서 찾기도 어렵고 중국 밖에서 정치하기는 더 어렵고
안정적인 공급망을 만드는 것은 더더욱 어렵습니다.
그렇다면 이 작은 금속이 왜 이렇게 중요할까요?
전기차 모터나 풍력발전기 안에는 강력한 자석이 들어갑니다.
핵심 재료 중 하나가 네오디뮴입니다.
네오디뮴 자석은 같은 힘을,
힘을 내면서도 더 작고 가볍게 만들 수 있습니다.
그래서 전기차 모터, 풍력발전기, 로봇, 드론, 미사일 유도정치에 들어갑니다.
문제는 열입니다.
모터가 빠르게 돌고 발전기가 강하게 작동하면 열이 발생합니다.
그런데 고열은 자석의 성능을 떨어뜨립니다.
뜨거운 환경에서 성능이 무너지면 고성능 장비 안에서는 치명적인 약점이 됩니다.
이때 등장하는 것이 디스프로슘입니다.
네오디뮴 자석에 디스프로슘을 조금 넣으면
고열에서도 성능이 떨어집니다.
더 안정적으로 유지됩니다.
그러니까 디스프로슘은 많이 들어가는 금속이라기보다
없으면 성능이 흔들리는 금속입니다.
그래서 디스프로슘은 히토류계의 미원처럼 보일 수 있습니다.
조금 들어가지만 산업 전체의 성능을 좌우한다는 겁니다.
그리고 여기서부터 이야기는 중국으로 넘어갑니다.
히토류라고 하면 사람들은 먼저 광산을 떠올립니다.
어느 나라 땅 속에 얼마나 묻혀있는지,
누가 더 많이 캐는지가 핵심처럼 보이죠.
하지만 히토류 공급망의 진짜 어려움은 채굴이 아닙니다.
히토류는 땅에서 캐는 순간 바로 산업자원이 되지 않습니다.
성광, 농축, 분리, 정제, 금속화, 합금, 자석 제조라는 긴 과정을 거쳐야 합니다.
특히 디스프로슘 같은 중위토류는 더 까다롭습니다.
서로 성질이 비슷한 원소들을 하나씩 분리해야 하고
그 과정에서 화학 공정이 반복됩니다.
환경오염도 크고 폐기물 처리도 어렵고
설비와 노하우가 모두 필요합니다.
중국의 진짜 힘은 바로 여기에 있는 겁니다.
중국은 히토류를 많이 캐는 나라일 뿐만으로는
히토류를 쓸 수 있게 만드는 정제와
자석 제조 단계에서 압도적인 위치를 차지하고 있습니다.
다시 말해서 다른 나라가 히토류를 캐도
중국으로 보내 정제해야 한다면
공급망 독립은 완성되지 않는다는 겁니다.
원유를 캐는 나라가 반드시 석유제품을 지배하는 것은 아닙니다.
정유공장과 유통망이 에너지 흐름을 쥐는 것처럼
히토류도 광산보다 정제와 자석 제조가 더 중요한 순간이 있습니다.
지금의 히토류 전쟁은 바로 그 전쟁이라는 것입니다.
이 불안은 이미 현실이 됐죠.
2025년 중국은 더비움, 디스프로슘, 루테튠 같은 중위토류와
관련 제품에 대한 수출 통제를 강화했습니다.
그때부터 디스프로슘은 단순한 광물 시장의 문제가 아니게 됐습니다.
공장 가동률의 문제가 됐습니다.
전기차 생산의 문제가 됐고
방산 공급망의 문제가 됐습니다.
그리고 국가 안보의 문제가 됐죠.
그래서 미국과 동맹국들은 중국 밖의 공급망을 찾기 시작했습니다.
첫 번째 길은 일본입니다.
일본은 육상 광산이 아니라 바다 밑을 보고 있습니다.
미남 히토리 섬 인근 해저 진흙층에서
디스프로슘과 더비움, 히토륨 같은 중위토류를 확보할 수 있다고 보고 있습니다.
육상 히토류는 토륨이나 우라늄 같은 방사성 물질과 함께 농축될 수 있습니다.
그래서 채굴과 재련 과정에서 방사성 폐기물이 문제가 됩니다.
반면 해저 히토류는 바닷물 속 히토류가 해저 환경에서
오랜 시간 걸쳐 흡착되고 농축되는 방식입니다.
쉽게 말하면 욕조에 물때가 끼듯이
바닷 밑 진흙층에 히토류가 쌓이는 겁니다.
일본은 2016년 2월 미남 히토리 섬 인근 약 6,000m 깊이에서
히토류 진흙을 회수했다고 밝혔습니다.
물론 산업화까지는 채굴, 운송, 분리, 정제, 경제성 검증이라는 긴 과정이 남아있습니다.
그러니까 일본의 해저 히토류는 당장 중국을 대체하는 답은 아닙니다.
하지만 중요한 신호겠죠.
일본은 자기 바다에서 새로운 우회로를 만들려고 하고 있는 겁니다.
두 번째 길은 호주입니다.
호주는 바다가 아니라 육상 광산을 보고 있습니다.
그 중심에 있는 기업이 노던미네랄스입니다.
노던미네랄스가 개발하려는 브라운스레인지는
디스프로슌과 터붐이 풍부한 중위토류 프로젝트입니다.
회사는 이 프로젝트에서 생산된 정광이
일루카의 애니에바 정제소로 공급될 예정이라고 설명합니다.
이 말은 꽤 중요합니다.
호주가 단순히 광산 하나를 더 개발한다는 뜻이 아니기 때문입니다.
광산에서 캐고 호주 안에서 정제하고
미국과 동맹국 공급망으로
연결하려는 구상입니다.
그러니까 노던미네랄스는 단순한 광산 회사가 아닙니다.
중국 밖 디스프로슌 공급망을 만들려는
미국과 호주 전략의 한 조각입니다.
중국이 이 회사를 그냥 지켜봤을 가능성은 낮습니다.
실제로 중국과 연결된 투자자들은
노던미네랄스 지분 확보를 시도했습니다.
호주 정부는 이것을 단순한 투자로 보지 않았습니다.
전략 광물 기업의 경영과 방향에
중국 자본이 영향을 미칠 수 있다고 본 겁니다.
중국은 반대로 말합니다.
정상적인 투자를
국가안보라는 이름으로 막는 것은
차별이라는 겁니다.
여기서 양쪽 논리가 부딪힙니다.
하지만 이번 사건의 본질은 조금 더 분명합니다.
호주는 중국 자본을 싫어해서 막은 것이 아닙니다.
중국이 이미 장악한 중이토류 공급망의
다음 고리까지 붙잡는 것을 막으려 한 겁니다.
그런데 여기서 가장 중요한 반론이 나옵니다.
호주가 광산을 지킨다고
정말 중국 의존에서 벗어날 수 있을까요?
아직은 어렵습니다.
히토류 전쟁에서 광산은
진짜 어려운 부분은 분리와 정제입니다.
라이너스는 2015년 말레이시아 시설에서
디스프로슘 사나물 생산에 성공했습니다.
중국 밖에서 분리된 중이토류를
상업적으로 생산하는 중요한 사례입니다.
하지만 이 길도 쉽지 않습니다.
말레이시아 정부는 라이너스의 운영 면허를 연장하면서도
2031년까지 방사성 폐기물 생성을 중단하라는 조건을 달았습니다.
이것이 히토류 공급망의 가장 불편한 진실이죠.
모두가 히토류는 필요하다고 말합니다.
전기차도, 풍력발전도, 방산장비도 필요하고
중국 의존도도 낮춰야 한다고 말합니다.
그런데 정작 히토류를 정제하는 공장은
자기 동네에 두고 싶어하지 않습니다.
그래서 중국이 오랫동안 강했던 이유이기도 합니다.
중국은 광산만 가진 것이 아니라
호염부담이 큰 정제 공정과
자석 제조 생태계를 함께 키웠습니다.
그리고 세계는 오랫동안 그 구조에 기대왔었죠.
싸고 빠르게 조달할 수 있었기 때문입니다.
그러나 그 대가가 이제 드러나고 있습니다.
중국이 수출을 조이면 자동차 공장이 흔들립니다.
중국 자본이 전략강물 기업에 들어가면
동맹국 정부가 개입합니다.
일본은 바다 및 진흙을 끌어올리고
호주는 외국인 투자 규제를 강화합니다.
이 모든 사건은 하나의 질문으로 연결됩니다.
중국 없이 디스프로슘을 쓸 수 있는가?
단순히 중국 없이 디스프로슘을 캘 수 있는가가 아닙니다.
중국 없이 분리하고 정제하고 자석으로 만들 수 있는가?
그 환경 부담을 중국 밖 사회가 감당할 수 있는가?
이 질문에 답하지 못하면
히토류 독립은 구호에 그칠 가능성이 매우 큽니다.
그래서 호주의 이번 조치는 중요하지만
완성 단계는 아닙니다.
이것은 시작입니다.
노던미네랄스의 브라운스레인지가 성공해야 합니다.
일루카의 애니에바 정제소가 가동되어야 합니다.
라이너스의 중히토류 분리시설도 환경 조건을 넘어야 합니다.
일본의 해저히토류도 경제성을 증명해야 합니다.
히토류 전쟁은 이제 광산 지도를 펼쳐놓고
어느 나라에 얼마나 묻혀 있는지를 따지는 단계에서 벗어나고 있습니다.
진짜 전쟁은 그 다음입니다.
누가 정제할 수 있는가?
누가 오염을 감당할 수 있는가?
누가 자석까지 만들어낼 수 있는가?
디스프로슘이라는 이름은 도달하기 어려운 것에서 왔습니다.
이름처럼 이 금속은 여전히 어렵습니다.
캐기도 어렵고 정제하기도 어렵고
정치적으로도 어렵고 환경적으로도 어렵습니다.
하지만 그래서 중요한 겁니다.
중국이 진짜 붙잡고 싶은 것은 단순한 광산이 아닙니다.
광산에서 자석까지 이어지는 전체의 길목입니다.
그리고 호주가 이번에 선을 그은 것도 바로 그 길목이죠.
히토류 전쟁의 승자는 더 많이 캐는 나라가 아닐 수 있습니다.
마지막에 웃는 나라는 중국 밖에서 끝까지 쓸 수 있게 만드는 나라일 것입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.